hello there the Internet I'm down I'm
down weird the slow mo guys and this
video is all about sort of odd and weird
slow-mo perspectives in there yeah I'm
quite lazy so when I make a cup of tea
or whatever I don't really like to stir
with a spoon so one of these stereo cups
and I've wanted to use this Pro blends a
few more times because it gets some
really interesting angles somewhere you
could never usually get lens and I
thought would be cool if we sort of
dunked it in a spinning drink you know
from high up like that but I don't
really have the sort of I mean you're
wobbling everywhere repeatable skills
yeah so we've got this camera slider
it's mounted vertically instead of
horizontally and has a counterweight in
a rope so we can actually mount the
camera on this and usually it's used for
sort of you know nice smooth vertical
shots we're gonna mount it like this not
recommend it it's a lot of weight this
is quite a small little head lovely
pretty good sir it's pretty much right
because there's a little plastic thing
in the bottom of this cup if you hit it
it will probably break and it's this far
away from hitting it so I think over
time it will sort of bend inwards when
it comes right to the bottom yeah I
always get zapped by American plugs yeah
me too
got that beard see yeah I'll go get it
that's got to be one of those mental
setups we've ever had I quite like it
the monitor being on the camera is too
too heavy on the sort of front end so
that's separate now it's got a longer
cable and I final operation is gonna
look something like this
it's actually quite sturdy for the
amount of weight on this tiny little
head all right you want to give us a
little demo of this Cup sure it's not
actually like a coffee cup is sort of a
mixing yeah thing but it really is about
it I wonder if we could get some shots
through the side it looked might look
cool and I've just seen that vortex in
slow-mo that's what I thought I thought
it would be pretty cool because it's all
messy down here and in slow-mo you're
gonna see some cool stuff I think all
right get it spinning a little bit more
in actually yeah that's maximum spin
height right there we go yeah
not that whoa is it good that's really
trippy get your face in that that is
mental what is going on there cuz it
sends slow motion it makes it look so
much like bigger it looks like you're
doing it to a giant pool yeah it's kind
of hard to get an idea of what the scale
of that isn't it yeah by the numbers
down the side the cup could easily be in
meters focus is banging it tracks it all
the way through down to the bottom
why I should probably mention is that
the widest possible aperture on this
probe lens is an f-14 so it is an
incredible sucker of light so we might
need to get a little bit of additional
light because the Sun inconsiderate not
bright enough what do you think yeah
I've got one of these this is wicked
actually it looks like I'm a you're in a
washing machine yeah should we put some
food coloring in at some point I think
yeah yeah sure and good stop oh yeah
okay look on that so smooth
it's wicked okay let's try with some
food coloring it's a light as well yeah
okay go for green first getting have yet
yep
as I come in add the coloring so when
you want really what we do as soon as
you start moving us that pretty much
yeah okay cool on light
and go whoa Oh trippy
that was really weird oh sorry
quit it sorry I forget I'd have to push
the button be more
okay let's have a little gander at this
Oh God
the glob came out like right next to me
whoa that's amazing is it good it's
really good
oh man it looks like do you know that
bit in Star Trek with this like that red
goo that turns into black holes yeah it
looks like that and it's like using
zero-g drops you see the one that hit
the side whoa yeah oh it's like skidded
down the side like a secondary drop love
it that was wicked and there's a bird
drop there and you're clearly moving
further and further down there that's so
cool
looks like the matrix now yeah all right
I'm gonna come down faster this time
okay so hopefully keep up with your Dro
Buell's okay three two one three two one
go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
next experiment yeah we're gonna do some
tea and pouring milk into tea see what
it looks like when it's poured from the
same weird perspective yeah I always
wondered what it would be like to be
milk this angle should show us this is
some solid tea as well as she I brewed
this for about 45 minutes okay get the
light ready yeah
three two one oh look it says waterproof
I'm not sure about milk proof oh okay
cow juice on it well looks like a look
into oh there's the milk Oh absolute
glob perfect look at that
Oh No I think
[Music]
i caked the lens you absolutely caked it
but I'm Lula did this moments where like
once the milk cookie watched it
what's the Belk is like subsided across
all the front it kind of looks like the
inside of someone's throat it looks like
a gun it looks like an iliac sure it
looks like I'm using those little
cameras that goes into people's a gun
yeah it looks like a it does compete
yeah colonoscopy with an ED let's go
it's quite satisfying really it really
is actually the thing is cuz I poured it
it's such a small hole to pour it into
and the lens is taking up most of the
space I can't help but because you've
got to pour it quickly yeah hit the lens
it's like wrapping around the lens and
falling down straight in front of it
yeah this lens actually does have a
light built-in for such a different
color temperature to the rest of the
lights were using I'm actually just not
using it and the shadows aren't that bad
yeah three two one go how's the T solid
I'd drink that have a sip it's cold
oh there yeah I didn't just make it I
guess it would steam up the lens of it
yeah is it better yeah I'm in VR world
again ah Oh a nice glob yeah solid globe
nice go up coming in the side Oh
oh I'm a fan of that that's lovely
I had nothing like a nice cup of tea
looks like the inside of a Chocolate
Factory it looks like Willy Wonka's a I
like when the milk initially hits it
like because it's spinning it sprays the
milk slightly towards the center yeah
and then all the little bits of milk
that are making it all the way to the
bottom are getting hit by the thing
that's very cool I think we've done T
proud there I think so as an Englishman
I'm quite pleased with that and I don't
take sugar in my tea I'm just sort of a
milk only saw boy we've got a B but uh
you like a bit a bit of sugar daddy a
little bit of sweet tea oh I like it
NATO two milk two sugars
NATO that's what it's cool is it yeah
okay so the Sun is sort of behind a
cloud now so we brought out Sun number
two for a little additional boost and
some dust bins and some dust bins
because we blew up all our C stands with
a Russian Canada alright oh so this rig
allows for a counterweight to make it a
lot less of a struggle to lift back up
but because I'm counting so much on
gravity
we've got nothing in this so I just let
go and it can before that yeah I need
this need the downside is that it's the
nightmare to hold in place and lift back
up after you've done it sixteen times
okay this is gonna be absolutely show
three two one drop
[Music]
yeah this gonna take some doing three
two one drop
look pretty good got tea on my lab coat
oh no you can be alright that's cool
folks moving fastest out of in class
three two one drop
Oh a toilet that's fine
ah the window focus is so small you want
to see it looks a little bit like a
meteor falling into a ocean
[Music]
pretty cool just think it's not as good
when the focus is further away oh it's
in focus longer three two one go right
in there that white I just couldn't stop
it
[Music]
what
Oh do one no to what oh my shoe
everything's hot everything's boiling
[Music]
the more we the more we're doing this
the more sort of loose each point of
failure is becoming something [ __ ]
worried it's gonna snap off eventually
three two one two one two one oh my dear
Oh God might be it ah might be it
it wasn't spinning at all is it just
completely just completely now why not
focus is it goodbye I think I think
that's as good as we're gonna get for a
manual system here and I think we just
need to take it all apart and if we do
anymore we'll have to just tighten it
all up and put it back together again we
have to turn out if the thing is it's
like hard to spin it and also drop it
and also time it yeah everything's
getting pretty hot and loosing our
lights running out of battery and you
could fry an egg on that that's so hot
isn't it hot I think we've got some
almost very good stuff and if we want to
nail that showing future we should maybe
get hold of a motion-control bit of moko
what do you think that yeah I think so
make my job a lot easier and your job
yeah
all right let's get this Phantom off
this poor tripod head alright I really
liked the footage we got although a
deceptively exhausting video to make
yeah for you especially I just have to
push a couple of buttons and shine a
couple of lights but anything with
timing is like mentally frustrating and
then with all this it was like
evidential sort of a workout having to
suspend the weight and drop it and catch
you over and over again yeah I mean I
think that was my favorite cup of tea to
look at but I can't imagine tasting it
would be very nice no sugar in the
bottom cold that's like yeah man
hopefully you enjoyed that video it's a
bit of an experiment to one but if you
like those kind of videos let us know
and maybe we'll use this combination of
items again get some even more cool
stuff you can subscribe to us we've got
a second channel and tune in for the
next video OPA I like this thing it's
really cool now what don't touch my
stuff
sorry that's your I don't touch your
stuff good point